ceci n'est pas du fromage c'est de
l'huile de palme blanche ferme au goût
que les meules de fromage mozzarella
peut-on lire sur le site de cosco dans
l'industrie alimentaire on appelle ça du
fromage analogues ce n'est pas un
fromage puisqu'il contient des
ingrédients laitiers le fromage analogue
est principalement composé d'eau et
d'huile de palme
c'est ça que vous avez déjà mangé de
francs
stéphanie choc et directrice des ventes
nationales chez wine food qui distribue
au canada sous la marque chef nutri
toute une gamme de fromages analogue le
procès sont énormément utilisé dans les
cafétérias d'école cafétéria corporatif
ensuite on est très institutionnel qu'on
parle de puteaux garderie maisons de
personnes âgées puis ensuite c'est les
chaînes majeures pizzeria restaurant on
abat burrito on habite au boss ont narré
blaster l'épisode chihuahuas sont faites
avec votre hommage certains sandwichs
vendus dans les dépanneurs et stations
services utilisent l'analogue tout comme
une multitude de produits d'épicerie
nous avons demandé à syntec
agroalimentaire spécialisée dans le
développement de produits
d'analysé des fromages analogue type
mozzarella mélange tex mex et en grains
de chefs nutri ecaso cheese acheté chez
cosco et mayrand en les comparant à
leurs équivalents on a regardé au visuel
on en regarde au niveau de la texture au
niveau du goût on ne construit une
grille d'analysé efficace chacun des
fromages pour tester la moto quoi de
mieux que la pizza la première
conférence avec les yeux ou visuel et un
aspect hui le plus perceptible dans le
produit analogue l'analogue est beaucoup
plus fondants du type je me dise où on
embauche alors que le fromage mozzarella
régulier lui voit offrir une certaine
consistance non non on bouge a aucune
différence pour moi l'action de celle-ci
le format des deux fours d'une dont
camer d'extraire ogouma préféré ce que
cela te dire lequel elle fromage est
analogue je pense que celui ci mais te
tromper le programme a dit m
et il n'y a pas qu'au goût que l'on peut
se tromper à la vue on peut aussi être
bernés un exemple malgré son nom la
compagnie casse hodges de colombie
britannique ne fabrique pas de vrais
fromages il faut être attentifs aux
indications sur les emballages si les
mentions de garnitures préparation de
style fromage fondu ou simili fromage on
est probablement en présence d'une
version analogues
si on regarde maintenant un match ô toi
visionnement un peu le même résultat
goal com servirait rouleau dans le resto
tout cas visuellement encore une fois le
tendance à dire que c'est banal en mai
ou juin de teck poule c moindrement 30
ans d'un couac à mort dans là c'est ça
tu fais très difficile effectivement le
visuel que nous guider vers quelque
chose alors les verts dexter est sûre
avec mon associé vu
les fromages analogues sont présents
bien discrètement depuis des décennies
le new york times on parlait déjà en
1977 on s'entend que la qualité a
énormément changé au début ça fond des
ports sas et ne serait pas c'est
vraiment comme d'âcre est vraiment un
feeling qu'on mettait beaucoup pour
l'intérieur de recettes auxquelles on
est encore à la veille ma gueule
tout ce que je peux dire c'est que c'est
bien fait
pas grand chose pour tromper nos sens
effectivement surtout destiné une
transformation surtout destiné à
christian nau sans son activité ça va
s'étirer sa faune sa gratte inexactement
mêmes performances qu'un vrai fromage
mais on parle de coup beaucoup moins
chère fille qui sont facilement
adaptable à toutes les recettes
en effet les économies sont
considérables un fromage analogue type
mozzarella souvent 7 $ de moins de kilos
que la vraie et dans le cas des mélanges
ses 5 $ de moins kg par rapport aux 100
% fromage pour couper dans les coûts
beaucoup de restaurateurs et
d'industriels vont donc mélanger
analogues et traditionnelle
c'est quand il ya deux pizzas 5 $ 100 %
du fromage qui a tué beaucoup de gens
vont commencer à mélanger 50 50 donc un
sac de 10 kg pour 2 kilos de fromage
puis beaucoup de gens peuvent aller
jusqu'à 75 pour ça donc 75% d'analogue
pour 25% de vrais fromages
dans nos tests il fut difficile pour les
experts de syntec tout comme pour moi de
distinguer clairement l'analogue du
traditionnel alors pour le consommateur
la tâche s'avérera ardu de distinguer le
vrai du faux sauf peut-être pour le
fromage en grains carré et on termine
avec la piscine celui-ci plus facile
faudrait faire lorsque les yeux fermés
pour pouvoir au niveau de la forme on
s'entend que comme à regret et tubes
très grandes références les québécois le
fromage en grain pour niveau de la
texture parce que nos églises en fonte
et par élevé
[Musique]
c'est vraiment
pas donné aucune résistance
bien que j'en ai un peu plus côté du
drame est patent plus que ça non plus et
mon niveau visuel la coloration de la
section sur la fourchette qui aurait
bien qu'ici dans ce biopic c'est bien
c'est bien faire un petit côté joe dante
le module en général l'industrie du
fromage analogue a bien fait ses devoirs
peu à peu le consommateur s'est fait à
l'idée sans le savoir s'est habitué à ce
type de produits est possiblement s est
habitué à se produire flexible comme
devenue sa référence pour un produit
transformé
le plus surprenant c'est du côté
nutritionnel malgré la présence d'huile
de palme les analogues ne sont au final
ni meilleurs ni pires moins de protéines
un peu plus de sodium mais équivalent en
termes de gras saturés
[Musique]
on remplacera jamais le fromage on sera
jamais aussi bon que le fromage plainte
aujourd'hui qu'on était un complément du
fromage
coûte pas grand-chose moteurs
toujours il ne peut ce fut troublé un
peu des coachs
[Musique]
le combat vous avez des vraies guitares
experts
ces gens lui donne par midam